try cakes oof it's a recipe I'm going to
talk I'm not a chef but it's something
where I take an entire pint of ice cream
vanilla and then I get a piece of cake
and I put it in a bowl and I just mash
it like a lunatic in it until it gets
like soupy and it's called cake soup
usually three hours before the show I
have a Cobb salad cuz it's got protein
greens exactly and then after the
reality four not three hours before
never at like five dollars show and then
afterwards I turn into a rabid animal
and I never crave like an after-show
salad so I want like a tuna melt or
pulled pork I see or eat a phone
hamburger yeah a full-on hamburger fries
fried food yeah so I admire artists that
say you know I'm just gonna have a
little protein and go to bed who's got
the tofu I do what you do like three
hours before it's gonna be like if I
chose it five at eight I got to be like
430-5 exactly i'll have like a half a
turkey sandwich with you know maybe some
pop chips or I'll have a salad anything
that has protein like you said